rosny sous bois on peut découvrir des
surprises telles que ces petits
pavillons de banlieue havre de paix
niché entre les aux immeubles
malheureusement il est prévu que ces
maisons de la rue philibert hoffmann
soient toutes détruites
en cause les travaux du tronçon est de
la ligne 15 du projet du grand paris
l'ouvragé déclaré d'utilité publique les
23 habitations concernées dans
lesquelles vivent en majorité des
personnes âgées l'on a pris brutalement
par une lettre envoyée par la société du
grand paris
la sgp le riverain jean françois boulay
est catastrophé on a reçu une lettre
ordinaire voyez même pas en recommandé
voilà donc cette lettre a dit qu' on a
besoin de vos terrains et nous on est
rentré dans la maison en 99-2000 quoi
juste à ce moment là voilà donc ça fait
un peu plus de vingt ans que nous sommes
là et on était venu là pour pouvoir être
tranquille pour la fin de nos jugements
à partir d'arreau dit bah écoutez
monsieur vous partez vous l'imaginez
quand même le choc que ça représentait
la déception bien sûr jean françois
boulay a organisé une pétition et fédère
les habitants sous le choc j'ai croisé
des gens sont trois toi moi je venais
chercher mon pain qui avait la lettre à
la main et il pleurait une personne de
80 ans pleurer en disant de l'aneth
c'est des gens qui vivent dans leur
pavillon pendant leurs souvenirs qu'on
leur habitude qu'ont leur patrimoine
affectif et tout ça et on leur dit vous
partiez en plus on vous raconte moi
j'espère avoir la force de négocier à
vous il ya peu près comment mais il ya
des gens comme toi vers 700 comment ils
vont négocier
il y a deux ans le tracé ne devaient
menacer qu'une école mais des études
complémentaires ont estimé qu'un ouvrage
appelé entonnant pouvait être réduit de
200 m en passant par un nouveau
périmètre la société du grand paris a
choisi ce scénario avec l'accord de
l'ancien maire de rosny sous bois
mais les habitants n'ont pas été
informés nous avons pu consulter un
document d' usage interne de la sgp
il prend acte du fait que l'ancien maire
a demandé de ne pas initier de contact
avec les propriétaires avant avril 2020
soit avant les élections municipales
un secret qui révoltent l'adjoint au
maire pierre olive et karel mis devant
le fait accompli est un véritable
déchirement non seulement d'avoir appris
de manière assez incidente le nouveau
projet mais également l'impact humain
que cela va avoir sur les résidents qui
sont là depuis tant d'années et on a
découvert au détour d'un compte rendu de
réunion qui a eu lieu au mois de juillet
2019 que l'ancien maire avait demandé à
la société du grand paris de ne n'avoir
aucune communication avant le mois
d'avril 2020 à l'époque n'avait pas
encore la perspective du confinement
donc c'était post élections municipales
lui il ya la ligne 1 15 mois à côté de
chez moi j'ai la ligne 11 donc n'importe
qui peut être concerné et on voit bien
que c'est les plus humbles qui trinque à
chaque fois aujourd'hui jean françois
boulay se sent bien seul
j'ai écrit au grand paris pour demander
une explication ils ne répondent pas
j'écris elle ne répond pas je suis tout
seul
contactée la société du grand paris
explique que ce nouveau tracé permet de
diminuer les nuisances du chantier est
de réduire sa durée
elle expliquant être qu'au tout début
des négociations et que pour cette
raison un contact téléphonique n'a pas
encore été initié la sgp promet
d'organiser une réunion en janvier et
d'accompagner chaque propriétaire au cas
par cas
reste la détresse des habitants dont la
maison et la tranquillité vont
s'effondrer